from being at Showtime what did you
learn about a-flat script versus a
viable script to me I'm looking for
something it's it's pretty basic it's
does it grab me and does it keep me
however they accomplish that is it does
it flow does it have a natural flow does
it make me want to turn the pages in my
training I learned somewhat how to do
that and then in subsequent experience
and study and we talked about it in the
books the the techniques that you can
actually do there are tools you can use
to keep the audience engaged but
essentially that was it I wasn't looking
or nor was I instructed to look for any
particular type of material I was just
handed things and some of the things I
did were reading stage plays like can we
make this into a Showtime on Broadway
production would that work sometimes
they'd send me off to see a theater
group that kind of thing and I'd have to
give him a report on my judgement on
that but beyond something that grabs you
and keeps your attention I'm not that
that's pretty much it now there was one
script and I I'll have to it'll have to
remain nameless
there was one script that I remember
from that time a couple years that I was
doing that and I thought this is funny
this is smart this is clever I sure hope
this gets made somehow and that was like
1983 okay 84 and time went on and then
sure enough it got made 20 years later I
thought oh that's great
same title but by then it had been so
rewritten that it was a famous disaster
and it was too bad but that would be an
example there was one that just the
cleverness of the writing the the way
the characters were so sharp the way it
flowed was
made me remember it it stood out in the
pile of material so interesting why do
you think so many whether it's hands got
you know in the pie or why do you think
that it had such a fresh voice and then
it was almost this is just my word but
destroyed maybe that's too strong but
well I have this not too strong
it's the mode of production I think in
at least four big movies is is a problem
I think because when you have a big
movie and this wound up being a big
studio movie I just think there's so
much pressure that it work that there's
defensive things that happen and we need
to make sure that the okay I'm not sure
this draft is right let's get another
writer in and then you know there's
there's so much at stake that it it has
an effect on the product and it can
become incoherent and it is a
collaborative medium and there's always
going to be even in the best of
circumstances you could have a great
writer director producer casts and and
script and it could still fall flat its
imprecise but there seems to be the
storytelling tends to flatten out in
these situations because one of the
elements of that I talked about more in
the first book about dramatic irony
dramatic irony is of course Alfred
Hitchcock used it create suspense to
create to use to create a story that
involves withholding some information
from the audience some information from
the characters when you reveal it that
requires someone who's really watching
it and imagining it in their own mind
the whole time and if you've got a lot
of people involved somebody's gonna go
oh my goodness we sure the audience is
going to get this well you better make
it clear and if it's clear it's risk
being boring the three three three
questions that Frank Danielle shared
with us that I still think apply to any
story he said there's three question
that you ask when you're crafting a
story 1 what does the main character
want and what are they trying to avoid
hey that's question 1 - what is the main
character know and what is the main
character not know and then the third
question is what is the audience know
what is the audience not know and I
don't think most writers realize that
you have control over those second two
that the audience especially when I work
with students the audience doesn't have
to know everything all the time and the
characters don't have to know everything
all the time
you can withhold some information you
can play games in fact my takeaway from
the book that Connie and I did this the
science of screenwriting see it that
came out last year was this applying
constructivist psychology to the
storytelling process this is something
that was in the 80s a film critic David
Bordwell came out with a blockbuster
scholarly work in which he squarely
placed storytelling in the realm of the
constructivist psychology and that
simply means that most of our experience
in life most of our experience of
reality is based not on knowledge but on
inferences that we make based on clues
so that you have what's called top-down
processing bottom-up processing is you
see things that goes into your brain and
you make note of it and you store
information top-down is you see
something in the world and your brain
automatically compares what you've
experienced before with what you're
seeing and then you make a conclusion
you know there's shortcuts that we're
doing all the time you've never seen the
back of this chair but you've seen
chairs so you assume the back kind of
looks like any other chair it would be a
surprise twist at the back of this chair
had a dragon hiding out there you know
because that's not normal what you're
normally associated with that concept so
in
when you're telling a story you're you
you if you understand that that's how
audiences are responding then how they
how they experience a movie is they're
looking for clues and they're going to
put them together and they're actively
involved in constructing a reality
you're the one as a screenwriter as a
storyteller you're giving them the clues
you're turning them and get in Frank
Danielle's term you're making them the
smartest people in the world you're
making them so brilliant because they're
seeing all these clues and you're the
one who's actually giving them to them
but they think they're figuring it out
and they're gonna try to anticipate
where you're going because they've seen
movies before the this is an ocean a
conceptual framework called a schema
they've seen a movie they know how
movies are they know they have tend to
have a character who does this and that
and when you know that you can play
games with them and that's the for me
the most fun thing about screenwriting
is creating worlds and driving people
crazy getting in their heads and you can
learn how to get in their heads just a
very simple example suppose I show you a
movie there's a shot of a husband and
he's buying the wife and his wife
flowers and chocolate and an anniversary
card okay
and on his way home from work okay then
meanwhile you see the wife has got a gun
and she's hiding it in the bedroom
drawer okay what are you gonna think
well it's pretty obvious isn't it he's
wants to make love and she has other
plans right okay that's where the
audience is gonna go and that's you
could pay it off that he comes home with
the flowers she pulls out the gun and
shoots him or you could then disclose
later that the gun that he's gun
collector and the surpri and this is a
present for him this is a gun he's been
looking for she saved up for it and she
wants to give it to him for anniversary
present and then you find out that he
poisoned the chocolate
so you we just told a twist is just
telling two stories at the same time the
one the audience thinks its seeing and
the one that's actually seen and you're
relying when you do that kind of thing
on the audience's propensity to figure
it out and be smarter than you and once
you've got them going that way you can
have all kinds of fun so that that's one
element of the constructivist psychology
that that we mentioned in the book and
have examples of the filmmakers doing
that you know doing that kind of thing
you